let's talk a little bit about why you
put your CSS tags in the header and your
script tags in the footer
maybe you've been told to do that but
you're not sure why if you're going to
be linking in your HTML document to an
external CSS or script if you're going
to put those in it's important that you
put those links in the right places
let's talk about why maybe you've seen a
web page where all of the text is loaded
and it looks like there's no additional
font there's no formatting and as the
page continues to load then it all kinda
goes into place and starts to look
prettier that is an example of a page
where the CSS is not necessarily in the
header and the script is not necessarily
in the footer there's an event called
Dom content loaded why that matters is
the Dom the document object model is
inside the browser and it's seeing all
the information from a web page from the
HTML the CSS and once it has all that
information loaded to a certain point
that do and we'll say okay it is loaded
enough for us to display it for the user
what could happen is the CSS is not in
the header the document object model can
think that it's ready to show the user
but the formatting hasn't actually
loaded yet same goes with the JavaScript
or whatever script you are using if it's
not in the footer that time where the
event happens the content loaded for the
document object model might not totally
line up for the best user experience
luckily the fix is easy do as you've
been told and put the CSS in the header
and the JavaScript in the footer to
ensure that your users have everything
load and be viewable to them when it's
actually the way that you want it to be
seen as all of these videos this is just
a simple and basic explanation check out
the link in the description for some
additional resources